now A woman has died and another has
been injured in a dog attack in Surrey
with seven dogs being rounded up by
police so let's find out more about this
uh Sky shiman Freeman Powell is at the
scene for us now Mama sounds absolutely
horrendous so what details do we have
well lots of the details are still
unclear I'm currently stood by the side
of a road this is a access road to
Gravelly Hill where the incident was
taking place yesterday after noon and as
you can see there's still a cording that
remains in place and this is one of many
cordons that are so in place around the
local area now what we do know is that
yesterday Emergency Services responded
to reports that his dog was attacking
members of the public Emergency Services
attended the scene but despite best
efforts by paramedics sadly a woman in
her 20s was pronounced dead now her
identity is yet to be revealed but we
have been told by police that her next
of kin had been informed and are
currently being supported by specialist
officers a second woman was also taken
to hospital with injuries as well
however police say that her condition is
not thought to be life-threatening now
as I say we are still waiting for much
of the details to be revealed to explain
exactly what happened here yesterday but
we have been told that the police were
supported by armed police and by help
with National Police Air Service to
round up around seven dogs and the
police say that those dogs are now in
police custody now we have had a
statement from police who say they
understand that this will be concerning
to the local community but they are
asking the community not to speculate
about what happened